What do we know about the vehicles impacted, Graham?
The vehicles impacted right now, NHTSA is saying it's a rare issue.
But it is about a few dozen models of Model S, Model 3, Model X...
...and Model Y vehicles between 2016 and 2023.
So, any Tesla vehicle produced in the last seven years is, you know,...
...could be considered part of this recall.
And I do recommend that if you own one of these vehicles,...
...to go on the NHTSA website and see if your vehicle is affected.
You know, a lot of our audience out there on Twitter, on other social platforms...
...like Instagram, they're saying why are you guys jumping on this?
It's a software fix.
Why are you calling it a recall?
Well according to NHTSA, it is a technical recall...
...but the other point that we make in our reporting, right,...
...is that Elon Musk has talked about how central FSD is to Tesla's valuation.
That's what he's talked about in the past.
Absolutely.
This is really about where he sees the company.
And as we've reported before, what is marketed as full self-driving or autopilot...
...often comes into conflict with the reality of the situation.
The company itself says on its website that full self-driving and autopilot...
...should not be enabled without drivers attention.
That the driver should always keep their hands available to take over.
And this marketing and even the labeling of full self-driving...
...has had people and critics and agencies complain about this.
This is also part of an ongoing investigation...
...that NHTSA has had into the company's autopilot and full self-driving technology.
So, this is a real risk for the company should this have any more faults...
...and be something that the U.S. government is investigating...
...a little bit more seriously.